ayant wissem qui étudiants victimes du
racisme alors on est dans la première
partie sur le racisme wissem est ce que
toi tu peux nous raconter ce qui
t'arrive et de coin tu es victime
c'est simple en fait ça a commencé très
tôt peut-être que le fait quoi dans la
vie
je suis étudiant en informatique
d'accord et donc donc je suis en
alternance les premiers les premières
fois où on fait ça m'est arrivé
bah tout simplement j'étais au lycée on
était en première
tout simplement on se préparait pour le
bac de français tu habitais ou xmg
habite en seine et marne d'accord à
moissy-cramayel plus précisément qui
n'est pas forcément réputé pour être un
endroit très très problématique il y en
a au contraire j'étais quand même dans
l'un des meilleurs lycées de cm1 et en
fait on se prépare est tout simplement
pour le bac de français et puis en fait
j'avais on était dans un petit groupe de
de révision et puis un camarade qui se
retourne et qui en fait s'en prenait une
personne un peu plus forte physiquement
qui était quand même complexé par par
son parent par son physique d'accord
simplement moi j'ai préféré intervenir
sans il y met trop du mois donc tout
simplement je lui demande d'arrêter de
l'embêter parce que ça me perturbe aussi
dans mon travail c'est pas tout
simplement lui dire voilà je suis fait
chier et en fait à partir de là il
mesure mais toi en fait ça te regarde
pas ferme là et retourne toi donc à
partir de là moi je commence à me
prendre un peu plus fortement et je lui
demande écoute bon là tu fais chier tout
le monde on n'arrive pas à bosser
moi je vais avoir mon bac si t'es pas
d'accord avec tu sors de la classe sinon
c'est moi qui te sortent et à partir de
là en fait si se lève et ému mais
retourne dans ton pays deçà l'émigré de
merde et à partir de là en fait moi
j'étais choqué c'est ça ouais si vous
vous attendiez pas à sa saison on
s'attend pas en fait surtout de la part
de quelqu'un qui à notre âge bien son
jeu si pâques en fête à 16 ans une
personne comme ça elle peut déjà avoir
autant de haine envers nous quoi tout
simplement moi je les prie pour moi mais
avec le recul et et et si vous voulez
avec la maturité que j'avais en fait
j'ai surtout compris plutôt comme une
attaque qui me choque qui m'attaquaient
pas forcément que personnellement mais
qui attaquait en fait toute une
population toute une commune et une
communauté mais que finalement en fait
ne sont que des origines puisque on est
français on est tous français
bien sûr et voilà en fait à ce partir de
là vous n'avez pas là vos parents que
vous êtes rentré soir vous n'avez pas
osé j'en ai pas fait j'en ai pas parlé
parce que pour moi en fait c'était un
s'ils voulaient c'était plutôt un acte
isolé à l'époque j'étais pas forcément
très en lumière de tout ça il ya eu
d'autres actes après ma à la suite de
cet événement là parce que non puisque
je lui ai fait comprendre qu'en fait
écouter qu'un sale idiot tu veut pas
grandir tu as 16 ans était déjà dans
cette mentalité bas a malheureusement
j'ai envie de te dire si tu change pas
dans deux ans tu es perdu mais après
voilà si c'était cessé de son ressort à
lui et aujourd'hui vous êtes vous êtes
victime de racisme
si vous voulez après suite à mon bas qui
en fait j'étais dans une école
d'ingénieurs et en fait première année
de prépa intégrée
je rentre il est 16 heures de jeu je
vais prendre les transports chat gare de
lyon donc je vais prendre le rer d pour
rentrer chez moi je me fais contrôler
par la police pour rien donc sûrement un
contrôle au faciès et la première chose
que je leur fais c'est jordi écouter
messieurs on en pleine heure de pointe
il ya au moins 400 personnes sur le quai
je leur demande directement à une pièce
d'identité et ma carte d'étudiant pour
leur montrer que je suis pas hostile et
que finalement je suis pas un danger
pour eux ni pour personne et je le redis
en fait ils me prennent il me pousse
contre le mur et me disait ferme-la
petit con et à partir de là je le redis
j'ai écouté messieurs vous êtes des
forces de l'ordre vous représenter notre
pays vous représentez les citoyens et
vous êtes censés nous protéger
angie toiture représente une menace pour
notre pays les gens comme toi sont une
menace pour le pays est en fait la gelée
réellement pris comme un affront très
compliqué et j'ai eu du mal à le digérer
quand on a 18 ans et toujours d'accepter
sa dîme et mohamed et c'est là qu'on se
rend compte que le racisme à plusieurs
formes s'appelle de l'agression physique
à l'agression verbale et puis assez de
toutes ces petites discrimination du
quotidien la balle de se faire tabasser
pour être victime de racisme
j'ai donné des exemples tous les jours
discrimination à l'embauché dans les
logements c'est plus compliqué lorsqu'on
peut se souvenir d'une communauté et
puis l effet du quotidien j'ai souvenir
j'ai un maître un ami médecin s'appelle
le docteur coulibaly
c'est probablement l'un des meilleurs
médecins que je connais très sincèrement
et on allait au parc des princes un jour
ce qu'on a on s'est dit voilà canton
restrictions réussi on pourra aller au
parc des princes et dans le métro
il avait acheté un poster pour une amie
qui est en chaise roulante et il se fait
arrêter par un policier qui nous dit
mais vous avez loin devant des posters
monsieur j mais attendez pourquoi vous
m'interpeller comme ça et dit bah oui
vous allez vendez vous avez une
autorisation ait dit non mais c'est un
poster pour une amie donc c'est toute
cette forme insidieuse qui sont très
blessantes auto finalement on se rend
compte que lorsqu'on parle
l'antisémitisme on s'attaque aux juifs
on s'attaque à la république parce que
finalement
d'ailleurs on s'attaque à donner jackson
on s'attaque à monsieur on s'attaque à
tout le monde et je pense qu un travail
d'éducation à faire un travail de fond